escribe 29 centésimos como un decimal
entonces empezaremos con 29 céntimos y
esto lo vamos a escribir como un decimal
y para eso vamos a descomponerlo para
poder obtener así su valor posicional
porque su valor posicional nos ayudará a
convertirlo en un decimal 29 centésimos
lo podemos descomponer de la siguiente
manera esto es lo mismo que tomarme 20
centésimos 20 centésimos ya esto sumarle
9 centésimos 9 centésimos porque 9
centésimos + 20 centésimos es lo mismo
que 29 céntimos pero ahora podemos
simplificar esto un poco y eso nos va a
ayudar a encontrar fácilmente su valor
posicional porque 20 centésimos esto lo
podemos simplificar de la siguiente
manera podemos dividir tanto arriba como
abajo entre 10 y
0 y este 0 se cancelarían entonces me
quedarían 2 sobre 10 o dos décimos ya
esto le voy a sumar estos 9 centésimos
no los olvidemos 9 centésimos bien y
ahora que tenemos los décimos y los
centésimos observa que estos son sus
valores posicionales puedes reconocerlos
entonces estamos llegando a que 29
centésimos es lo mismo que dos décimos
déjame ponerlo así dos décimos
+ 9 céntimos más
9 centésimos
y esto nos va a ayudar mucho a encontrar
su valor posicional centésimos tengo dos
décimos que son estos que tengo aquí y
nueve centésimos que son estos que tengo
aquí así que ahora podemos ya tomarlos y
pensar justo en su valor posicional
porque si nosotros ponemos por aquí el
punto decimal déjame ponerlo por aquí
del lado izquierdo del punto decimal
vamos a tener el valor posicional de los
enteros empezando por las unidades que
en este caso no tenemos ningún entero 10
por eso que pondré aquí 0 muy bien y
ahora lo que sigue después del punto
decimal a la derecha es empezar con los
décimos pero aquí dice que tenemos dos
décimos entonces en esta posición voy a
poner el valor de 2
y decimos y después de los décimos
tenemos los centésimos y aquí pondremos
el valor que tenemos del 2 centésimos
que es de 9 tenemos 9 centésimos
entonces el valor que toman los
centésimos es de 9 y ya aquí tenemos
0.29 o 29 centésimos que es lo mismo que
la fracción 29 centésimos 29 sobre 100 y
escucha cómo se leen 29 centésimos y
aquí tengo 0.29 o 29 centésimos así que
lo hicimos bien es por eso que la
fracción y el decimal se leen de la
misma manera y esta es una pista
adecuada para saber que lo hicimos bien
entonces 0.29 o veintinueve centésimos
es lo mismo que 29 sobre 100 o 29
centésimas ahora qué te parece si quito
todo esto y vamos a hacer uno más voy a
traer este siguiente ejercicio
escribe 53 décimos como un decimal y de
nuevo vamos a descomponerlo aquí voy a
poner 53 décimos y bueno esto va a ser
igual a quien bueno esto es lo mismo a
50 decimos muy bien y a esto sumarle
tres décimos más tres décimos más y
ahora esto lo podemos simplificar un
poco porque 50 decimos esto lo podemos
dividir tanto arriba como abajo entre 10
y no quedarían 5 sobre 15 veces 1 ya
esto no hay que olvidar que tenemos que
sumarle tres décimos ahora bien ya aquí
tenemos los valores posicionales y vamos
a escribirlos esto es lo mismo que cinco
veces uno o cinco sobre uno es lo mismo
que 5
a veces esto es muy importante tengo 5
unidades ya esto le podemos sumar tres
décimos entonces le vamos a sumar tres
décimos
muy bien ahora ya que tenemos escrito de
esta forma su valor posicional vamos a
traer por aquí nuestro punto decimal que
va a estar justo por aquí y recuerda que
a la izquierda del punto decimal tenemos
los enteros empezando por las unidades y
esta vez si tenemos unidades tenemos
cinco unidades por lo tanto aquí en la
posición de las unidades pondré el valor
de cinco y bueno a la derecha del punto
decimal tengo los decimales empezando
por los décimos y en este caso tenemos
tres décimos es justo lo que dice aquí
entonces voy a poner aquí tres décimos y
ahora sí puedo decir que 5.3 esto de
aquí es la forma decimal de la fracción
53 decimos es decir escribir 53 decimos
como un decimal va a ser lo mismo que
tener 5
y tres decimos que es lo mismo que
escribir 5.3 y ya acabamos